un guiño en el terreno donde es más
fuerte su competidor en la recta final
del proceso electoral de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva intenta el
acercamiento a los evangélicos el
colectivo de votantes donde es más
fuerte su rival en una carta abierta Se
compromete a respetar la libertad de
culto expresa su admiración por la obra
social de la iglesia evangélica y da la
bienvenida a esta comunidad religiosa en
su gobierno de resultar electo; el
presidente Jair bolsonaro insistido en
que Lula perseguirá los cristianos como
lo han hecho según él otros gobiernos
autoritarios e izquierda y muchos de sus
seguidores evangélicos le creen
desde el gran apoyo que le damos al
presidente bolsonaro es por su
autenticidad por lo que es el expresa lo
que es y no es la marioneta de nadie
Lula aprovecha una reunión con
representantes e iglesias evangélicas
este miércoles para responder algunas de
las preocupaciones sembradas durante la
campaña como la introducción de baños
unisex en las escuelas
tengo una hija una nieta y una bisnieta
solo puede haber salido de la cabeza de
Satanás la historia de los baños unisex
solo de ahí
los evangélicos constituyen un tercio de
la población brasileña y una fuerza
electoral en la que bolsonara encuentra
un poderoso bastión a menos de dos
semanas el balotaje las encuestas
revelan un leve fortalecimiento de la
opción del presidente